question l'école est-elle un nid à kovy
de l'école at-elle les moyens de
prémunir enseignants et élèves du virus
sont bien faut-il à tout prix conserver
les écoles ouverts ne serait ce que pour
l'éducation des enfants place à notre
décryptage avec nos invités pour en
parler avec nous en direct
hubert salle à un porte-parole de la pp
fédération des parents d'élèves de
l'enseignement public nicolas guy hier
professeur de français et mister du
mouvement les stylos rouges avec nous
également en direct alexis poulain à
notre éditorialiste bonsoir à tous les
trois messieurs merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france à verser votre
mouvement
nicolas glières les stylos rouges avec
plusieurs syndicats qui appelaient à la
grève demain vous dit en substance nous
sommes livrés aux qu'ovide enseignants
élèves et familles vous vous sentez
réellement en danger dans vos
établissements dans vos fonctions alors
complètement rien qu'aujourd'hui dans
mon établissement est dans ma classe
dans une de mes classes 2 4 co lead et
quelques élèves ont été déclarées qu'à
contacter par la rs tous les autres
étaient collés à l'élève concerné qui
étaient collés aux autres dans les
couloirs dans les salles dont les
escaliers à la cantine et avec les
proches
donc on est tous en danger de ce fait là
parce qu'on a voulu à tout prix mettre
tous les élèves dans des salles et des
bâtiments exigus nous demandons depuis
quatre mois les denis groupe 4 mois et
en collège ce n'est pas mieux quand
l'iss
donc on ne comprend pas bien pourquoi le
gouvernement refuse à tout prix j'ai une
info assez exclusive
on a quelqu'un de la rs qui nous a
contactés nous les stylos rouges pour
nous dire que la demande avait été faite
à la rs ile-de-france du denis groupe
le gouvernement a refusé obstinément
voilà où on en est on a aucun dialogue
possible avec ce ministre il veut nous
envoyer attraper le coup livide
il ne nous protège pas et ne protège pas
les enfants il ne protège pas les
familles où on est en danger c'est pour
ça qu'on porte plainte et on n'est pas
entendu donc il nous reste la grève
mais qu'est ce que veut dire la grève ça
veut dire que demain je vais perdre du
salaire pour faire le gouffre du
gouvernement c'est à dire me défendre
défendre les élèves et défendre leurs
familles du co lead ça va me coûter de
l'argent
hubert salins vous partagez cet avis
relais récents précise en la rangeant
son régionale de santé un ministre
apparemment d'après nicolas denis hier
qui est sourd aux demandes vous partagez
cet avis les conditions sanitaires ne
sont pas réunies dans les établissements
scolaires les conditions sanitaires ne
sont pas très bonnes dans les
établissements scolaires mais comme
c'est le cas dans toute la société
je pense que les tout le monde ces
courses les chercher son pain à la main
il n'y a pas d'endroit pour traiter dans
la société et je pense que les idées
sont les collèges comprend pas les pires
des endroits si les protocoles sans
respect et correctement si elle juge n 6
a eu la place demain si à des nettoyages
en condition suffisante sur les utilise
tous les moyens possibles car les choses
alors on va pas on va papa lé là vous le
l'enseignant par des qu'il fallait
depuis quatre mois être à 50% mais le
sait sont les élèves qui vont payer
d'arrivée parce que on va nous faire
croire que les élèves à 50% du temps
dans l'établissement ils vont avoir les
mêmes apprentissage et la leçon qu'on a
eue au printemps justement c'est que les
professeurs sont indispensables à leur
place une classe des besoins d'un
professeur a besoin d'un professeur qui
ne fasse pas simplement un cours en
vidéo et qui circuit dans sa classe qui
explique aux élèves qui les interactions
voilà donc effectivement c'est pas
facile mais la fine et confortable pour
personne en ce moment et encore moins
pour les élèves et les élèves et on le
voit pas son dans les études ils sont en
difficulté ou en détresse psychologique
avec ses poulains c'est une situation
compliquée parce qu'on comprend les uns
comme les autres qui sont dans des
situations difficiles vous voyez faire
la grimace quand
nicolas guilherme disait voilà on n'est
pas entendus par par ce gouvernement
pas du tout ce gouvernement met en
danger les familles les élèves les
professeurs les personnels
administratifs dans un aveuglement
idéologique totale un aveuglement même
volontaire quand on écoute jean michel
blanquer dans les interviews qu'il donne
dans les médias français
on a l'impression que tout va bien il
nous sort des chiffres d'un chapeau 3500
élèves qui auraient été contaminés des
chiffres qui sont faut évidemment il
fait croire que les protocoles sont mis
en place
enfin c'est quand même incroyable et
j'espère que la population française
sera à vent debout derrière les
professeurs pour les défendre dans la
façon qu'ils ont de vouloir défendre et
les élèves aient eux-mêmes devant ce
gouvernement irresponsable
la rentrée de septembre n'a pas été
préparée du tout aujourd'hui jean michel
blanquer se réveille trois mois plus
tard pour essayer de préparer finalement
ce qui aurait dû être mis en place
durant l'été mais on a vu que durant
l'été
jean michel blanquer avait autre chose à
faire que préparer la rentrée le
problème il est là c'est qu'on a un
gouvernement qui fait semblant de gérer
cette crise sanitaire et qui ne fait
rien que gérer les conséquences pénales
qu'ils pourraient avoir parce qu'ils
sont responsables
et aujourd'hui on voit bien ça s'active
ça commence un peu à bouger
sarr confine parce que oui il ya
plusieurs plaintes au pénal contre les
ministres contre d'anciens ministres et
contre même l'ancien premier ministre
edouard philippe
donc oui ce gouvernement a été nulle
depuis mars dans la gestion de cette
crise sanitaire et particulièrement dans
ce nouveau confinement qui n'en est pas
un mais ni sa date de confinement posé
mais a pardonné à la voile à l'impératif
économique parce que ça semble être un
gros monde enfin canton mais voilà les
aider les enfants à la maison c'est
compliqué tout simplement pour les
parents de travailler mais mais c'est
pas compliqué pour le gouvernement de
d'empêcher les petits commerçants de
travailler de faire fermer les commerces
de faire fermer des rayons soi disant
non essentiels dans les grandes surfaces
le la façon dont cette crise est gérée
totalement ubuesque fait que de toute
façon
l'économie va être
et en miettes par ce nouveau confinement
aujourd'hui on est dans une économie
zombie un massivement subventionné avec
des milliards d'argent de la bce pour
faire croire que tout va bien pour payer
du chômage partiel mais en 2021 si
l'activité ne reprend pas et elle ne
reprendra pas elle ne peut pas reprendre
dans ce cadre actuel du coc vide eh bien
nous aurons là les faillites réel donc
ça m'embête pas le gouvernement de créer
de la faillite d'un côté alors pourquoi
faudrait-il que les enfants aillent à
l'école pour soutenir l'activité
économique puisque de toute façon cette
activité économique pour de nombreux
concitoyens elle est rétablie elle est
finie donc non il y à là et je crois à
un aveuglement idéologique grave parce
que aujourd'hui si le gouvernement écrit
yachts et ce serait la santé des
français et ce serait donc organisé un
confinement efficace ou des mesures
efficaces et pour cela je ne vois pas
pourquoi les écoles seraient ouvertes
autre chose on a parlé de l'enseignement
à distance
rien n'a été fait par l'éducation
nationale pour organiser l'équipement et
des familles et des établissements pour
que l'établît et que l'enseignement à
distance de qualité puisse avoir lieu
donc oui il est surtout extrêmement dago
logique inégal importe quel prix alors
pour savoir de quoi on parle on va
regarder les chiffres de santé publique
france le dernier bulletin
épidémiologique qui est date du 15
octobre dernier il ya effectivement des
interrogations regarder en milieu
scolaire et universitaire 12500 96 khz à
814 kloster au total nicolas guerre est
ce que vous avez des chiffres précis
parce que ça ce sont des chiffres
effectivement mais mais le nombre de
professeurs vraiment malade parce qu'on
le sait on le répète quand même
suffisamment et les médecins les
premiers ce virus n'est pas un danger à
priori pour les enfants
fort heureusement combien de professeurs
touché parce que c'est ça la vraie
question aujourd'hui alors sur le sur
une page notre groupe facebook les
stylos rouges
on a beaucoup de professeurs qui
témoigne à voir ulcos jce de la voix
rauque or en ce moment là vous rattraper
à l'école au collège ou lycée pour
l'argument des enfants qui seraient plus
mal à faire un un cours à jour sur deux
en demi groupe donc je rétorque vraiment
quelque chose il faut que les parents
nous entende on a besoin de leur soutien
oui ils ont raison il faudrait que les
enfants soient tous les jours à l'école
nous sommes d'accord mais là il ya une
épidémie qui tue qui laissent des
séquelles même aux jeunes et il faut
être raisonnable
il faut que tout le monde fasse un
effort les profs en fond je suis désolé
de le dire c'est peut-être dur ensemble
mais quel paquet lequel est forte pour
les parents pour le moment aucun donc là
il ya quelque chose on va on va
peut-être donner la parole justement à
la fédération des parents d'élèves pense
que ça n'a pas été un moment
spécialement facile le confinement avec
l'école à la maison
saleh et là j'entends dire que les
parents ne font aucun effort n'est pas
possible il ya des gens qui ont perdu la
moitié de leurs revenus
je pense pas que ce soit le cas des
enseignants la vie est difficile pour
bien des gens les gens plus entreprises
les commerces les commerces dont vous
parlez leurs parents sont chez nous les
en france il ya les enfants de
commerçants ti difficultés et les
personnes qui ont perdu leur travail
il ya des personnes qui avaient des
petits boulots qui faisait des ménages
dans les hôtels qui ont perdu leur
travail et qui sont des parents d'élèves
alors dire que c'est facile pour les
parents c'est insultant ses auditeurs
mais je pense que parfois quand vous
dites être raisonnable des fois de
raisonnable c'est cesser se lancer
courageusement les férias science le
menu complet elle raisonnable c'est pas
forcément se dire tout le monde rentre
chez soi votre boulanger il est
raisonnable quand il fait du pain le
matin aux commerçants qui sont
raisonnables quand ils travaillent les
gens qui font fonctionner tous les
services publics sont raisonnables la
personne qui va être à la station
service ou dans les magasins il est
raisonnable il fait son travail et il
s'engage et aujourd'hui la vie n'est pas
confortable n'est pour personne elle
n'est pas pour les parents en plus
contrairement à ce que vous dites
ce qui est quand même très irrespectueux
et qui est vraiment un manque de
considération pour les parents
effectivement c'est difficile pour les
professeurs nous on s'en rend bien
compte
c'est très difficile nous par exemple ce
qu'on dit c'est que si les régions si
les départements avaient fait les
efforts de m deux trois personnes en +
4/5 personnes en pluie dans les
établissements pour faire du nettoyage
pour fluidifier les choses à la cantine
si on avait permis d'être toutes sortes
d'aménagement comme ça on aurait pu
passer au niveau du confinement
là on va avoir des données qui va
manquer
plusieurs mois de cours certains ses
élèves de 3e par exemple qui n'ont pas
eu cours pendant quatre mois qui sont
rentrés au lycée il doit y avoir des
plans pour les aider pour les envies
empêcher qui coule et voila voila on va
laisser couler ses élèves la nicolière
nicolas deshaies race et voilà ces
petits piques que vous envoie cette
bonne guerre on est là pour débattre
la fédération des parents d'élèves vous
répondez quoi parce que je crois que
demain vous demandez aussi l'extension
de ce protocole sanitaire aux collèges
et aux primaires tout à fait je répète
ce que j'ai dit nous demandons le demi
groupe ça veut dire que les élèves ont
cours un jour sur deux par exemple et
l'autre demi journée nous demandons
depuis quatre mois que dès que les
collectivités locales les prennent en
charge
quand les parents ne peuvent pas les
garder deuxième joue ce n'est pas du
tout ce qu'on a dit deuxième n'ont aucun
élève n'a pas eu cours pendant quatre
mois c'est un mensonge tout simplement
nous avons fait cours à distance nous
étions parmi les seuls à travailler
donc je le dire à le dire quand même
avec les personnels soignants il faut
quand même pas dire n'importe quoi ça
c'est irrespectueux justement les élèves
n'ont pas perdu quatre mois de course et
tant de mensonges absolus de le dire et
c'est insultant pour l'intégralité du
corps enseignant qui a bossé pendant ce
temps là nous n'étions pas payé nous
n'étions pas payé à rester chez nous
nous étions payés à travailler ça il
faut vraiment insister pour le dire
parce que le prof bashing à deux
semaines du meurtre de sa belle pâti
tout le monde avait la larme à l'oeil
là encore deux semaines aujourd'hui on
se lâche un journaliste de france
culture vous un peu là c'est un peu
limite
on demande le 2 micros voilà on est on
vous êtes forcément d'avis différents on
est là pour débattre et on essaye de
modérée sur le plateau tout à fait nous
ce qu'on demande c'est ce demi groupes
et concrètement ça permettrait que les
élèves ne soient plus en danger les uns
avec les autres
aucun protocole ne peut fonctionner en
classe entière avec l'intégralité des
élèves c'est juste du bon sens et c'est
pour ça qu'on demande d'appui des
parents parce que c'est du bon sens pour
tout le monde
quel est le seul moyen d'empêcher la
fermeture des établissements qu'on ne
veut pas que les parents ne veulent pas
que nous ne voulons pas celle de nick
groupe pour tous et ça il faut vraiment
l'entendre moi je sais plus comment dire
on ne sait plus comment le désert alors
il ya la grève c'est sûr dès la logique
qui a les chiffres aussi comment le coup
vite va ralentir si les clusters que sur
les écoles collèges lycées restent
ouverts en intégrale
tous les élèves qui pullulent avec le
cogite concrètement dans les classes des
classes pas assez nettoyer elle devrait
pour être efficace à nettoyer chaque
heure est ce possible
non absolument pas en classe entière
donc voilà c'est factuel c'est ce que je
vis au quotidien je peux en témoigner je
peux vous le dire elle est que ce n'est
pas possible d'empêcher la contamination
avec les écoles ouvertes à 100% quand
jean-michel la blancarde 17 à chaque
lycée de s'adapter il est pas là
justement le problème c'est que dans le
fond chaque directeur d'établissement se
retrouve avec ses responsabilités ce qui
crée effectivement voilà des détentions
le sang elles sont bien légitimes des
deux parts et d'autres complètement
alors ça c'est une des grandes eaux ces
deux grandes obsessions de blogueurs
monsieur blanc car on a énormément
d'ailleurs et il veut être tout prix
faire du local toujours en fait tous des
composés tout enlever au niveau national
c'est son dogme libéral
concrètement il veut tout libéraliser et
c'est ce à quoi on assiste alors en gros
il a plus de règles nationales
il ya plus de règles communes on est en
république la règle doit être commune
pour tous alex pella avec ses poulains
justement sur cette accusation de vie
bas de vouloir être trop libérale de la
part de jean-michel bancaire jean michel
blanquer refait ce que fait le reste du
gouvernement c'est à dire qu ils
détricotent l'état ils organisent la
faillite de l'état l'éducation nationale
c'est un trésor c'est ce qui fait pour
beaucoup la république on en a parlé
longuement ensuite à la décapitation de
ça mais elle pâtit on comprend bien
l'importance de cette éducation
nationale même si eric ciotti voudrais
que tout le monde soit dans le même
moule c'est pas ça à l'éducation
nationale s'est donné à chaque citoyen à
chaque jeune de france
les moyens de réaliser ce qu'il est
réellement de réaliser son destin et
pour ça c'est la culture c'est le savoir
et c'est à l'école qu'on la prend donc
ses c'est extrêmement important et ce
que fait jean michel blanquer
il déconstruit l'école avec il gère la
pénurie exactement comme à l'hôpital on
demande aux soignants de faire
l'impossible et de gérer la pénurie
quand les plaignants demandent des
moyens on leur répond non il faut vous
organiser autrement
et puis on va pas faire de la dette
alors la dette on en fait beaucoup en ce
moment parce qu'il faut sauver les
banques il faut sauver l'économie
mais non il va aussi falloir sauver
l'éducation nationale sauver l'hôpital
et pour ça c'est quoi c'est plus de
professeurs c'est plus de médecins plus
de soignants c'est des gens qui vont
être formés pour être face aux élèves
face aux malades et s'est arrêté avec
sony au management de la terreur du dos
de la feuille excel de dudu du profit
parce que c'est ça que fait jean michel
bancaire gérer la pénurie et faire que
l'école soit rentable non un service
public il n'est pas là pour être
rentable et le néo management public qui
est à la manoeuvre depuis une trentaine
d'années a atteint sa limite c'est à
dire qu'on a vendu l'état à capable
incapable de fournir des services
publics incapables aussi de gérer une
crise majeure comme celle du co vide
regardez simplement l'état de faillite
dans lequel on se trouve
parce que nos élites nos chers élus font
croire qu'ils gèrent la crise mais non
ils gèrent simplement leurs
communications personnelles et le risque
pénal
face à cette mauvaise gestion de la
crise parce que l'état est aujourd'hui
incapable de faire face à une crise
comme celle ci est incapable de faire
que l'école soit de qualité
ben salah là on a un petit peu débordé
le cadre de la gestion de l'épidémie par
par l'école m'enfin sur ces critiques de
la part de l'éducation nationale vous
justement en tant que fédération des
parents d'élèves vous avez quelle quelle
vision seulement on fait ce qu'on peut
sur sur le terrain avec les moyens du
bord ce sera tout le monde sait toujours
ce qu'il peut avec les moyens du bord
voilà après les moyens imaginaire ou des
moyens ou rêver voilà si on les a pas il
faut bien travailler après l'âge on ne
va remettre sur sur cette question là
toute la politique qui a été fait par
rapport au niveau éducation nationale
depuis depuis plus de trois ans
maintenant
mais là quand j'entendais par exemple
d'enseignant dire que que qu'il faut
quelque chose de national qu'il faut pas
de solution locale des proviseurs mais
nous
ce sont les professeurs qui sont dans
leurs classes qui ont leur liberté
pédagogique on les approuve justement
quand ils disent qu'il ne faut pas
seulement la solution nationale avec des
choses qui te semble directement de
ministères avec des consignes fait
l'autre court comme ceux ci comme cela
nous fait confiance aux enseignants
quand ils sont dans leur casse qui sont
ceux qui connaissent le mieux leur et
des îles en la liberté pédagogique et
ils font leur travail
on n'a pas besoin ce mandat d'accord le
ministre qui leur dit quoi faire donc il
ya des moments il faut effectivement des
choses au niveau national mais on fait
aussi confiance au terrain on fait aussi
confiance aux professeurs ont fait aussi
confiance aux provisions
nicolas glières le mot de la fin va
trois réponses ça n'a juste aucun
rapport en fait la liberté pédagogique
c'est faire confiance aux enseignants
que nous sommes parce qu'on a su
recruter sur un concours difficile pour
enseigner pour transmettre mon savoir
aux élèves
là où parle d'une crise sanitaire
majeure international et l'on parle
d'une épidémie qui est dangereuse pour
tout le monde je voudrais aussi ajouter
rapidement par rapport à ce que votre
bandeau malheureusement ça ne concerne
pas du tout où les lycées justement
monsieur blanc qu'un ne voulais pas que
ça soit du tout mais en place il a fini
par vaguement cédé pour quelques lycées
en fait c'est aucun lycée pro déjà il
faut le savoir il ça doit concerner 400
à 500 mille élèves au maximum
donc ce n'est pas vrai il ya 12 millions
et demi d'élèves en france ce n'est pas
tous les lycées du tout il s'est arrangé
pour que ce soit le moins possible
vraiment nous nous demandons à ce que ce
soit étendue partout primaires collèges
et lycées pour la sécurité de tout le
monde dans une bonne intelligence avec
des cours à distance des cours en
présence pour le bien des élèves pour le
nôtre pour celui des familles pour la
santé de tous c'est le seul moyen de
sortir de cette épidémie c'est une
certitude et des médecins le disent trop
peu en france
énormément à l'étranger merci en tout
cas à tous les 3 hubert salle 1 nicolas
glières alexis poulain d'avoir été avec
mon d'avoir accepté ce débat merci à
vous